[Music]
I'm Michelle Miller from CBS Saturday
morning welcome to the dish today we
satisfy your sweet tooth with delectable
desserts hot and fresh baked goods and
edible works of art from across the
country we start with a slice of the
good stuff pie and More Pie from the
master herself Aaron McDowell who taught
me the secret to making a great crust
and much much more
it's a Pumpernickel pie crust with
sesame seeds avocados lemon juice and
some chili flakes to get a little slice
double crust chicken pot pie because the
crust is only on the top that is my
favorite apple pie these are mixed berry
hand pies it is a tomato tart to tan
which is an upside down puff pastry pie
sweet or savory Aaron Jean McDowell
lives and breathes pie what is it about
pie that separates it from all of the
desserts well I grew up eating a lot of
pie so I think that there's definitely
like a big pie making tradition in the
midwest pies are kind of a unique thing
with this very flaky crust with a huge
array of different fillings and a huge
array of different toppings and that's
why I love them is just because I've
been around them so much eyes were part
of her childhood she grew up making them
in her grandmother's kitchen my name is
Erin Jean is my middle name and it's my
grandma's name which is why I use my
full name and everything because she's
the one who taught me to make pie oh
so I always use my full name as a little
homage to her who doesn't love being in
their grandmother's kitchen it's one of
my Fondest Memories and that's
absolutely one of the places where I
fell in love with baking
she's been perfecting her technique and
recipes ever since but making a really
good pie crust ain't easy that's also
true and I just don't know why it's so
hard well I think the number one
ingredient that people forget about with
pie crust is actually their hands or
whatever the tool is that they're using
because the ingredients are simple in my
pie dough there are four ingredients
flour salt butter and water and ice
water and ice water yes very good and
cold butter cold butter sometimes I even
put the bowl of flour in the freezer for
a little while before I start mixing but
it's really not so much about the
ingredients it's about the technique
did you ever have the discussion with
your Gran you know what I'm pretty good
at this I need to go to Pi School the
inspiration for going to culinary school
actually came from some other members of
my family I have three older brothers
and two of them are artists and I
desperately wanted to be an artist but I
didn't seem to have any natural skill
with pencils or paints or anything and
then one day I came home from an art
class A Ceramics class and my mom was
making a cake and she was using a tool
that I had used in the ceramic studio
and it was like this huge light bulb
moment where I was like what if food is
my medium and so I started right then
and there I was about 15 years old and I
started making a whole bunch of really
awful cakes they were just terrible
so McDowell decided to get some real
life training after I got my first job
in a bakery I realized it is an art form
I could really do this the summer after
my senior year when most kids are like
you know hanging with their friends all
the time I was going to bed at 7 pm so
that I could wake up in the middle of
the night and go to work but it was
there that I realized oh my gosh I
really love this which gave her the
confidence to apply to the famed
Culinary Institute of America the first
time I went I went with my parents to
tour it they said that the smile on my
face it was my first time being there
and I was just like it was it was like
meant to be I couldn't imagine going
anywhere else from the first day I set
foot on that campus
a lot of recipes tell you how to do
something
but I like to know why I'm doing it
since graduation the 33 year old has
become a food stylist I wrote the book
on pie author and a baking consultant on
food 52.
a recipe in cookware site you have two
cookbooks under your belt what's next I
want to just keep teaching so I love
doing these videos I'm trying to show
the mistakes as well as showing the
success oh my God that is brilliant I
just want people to see you know recipes
say but don't over mix it but what does
over mixing look like what is it because
no one knows and then they over mix it
right I believe the mistakes are what
get us to Perfection 100
after the break we Taste the rainbow of
a classic Italian American treat that's
next on the dish
[Music]
there are small Sweet Treats typically
baked in the color of the Italian flag
red white and green then layered with
jelly and topped off with chocolate CBS
Sunday morning's Khalifa cine shows us
The Art of the rainbow cookie from its
home in New York City
it's baking it's what I do it's what I
love you want to get it into all the
corners Samantha Zola is obsessed
rainbow cookies should be colorful they
should incorporate every color of the
rainbow she started Zola bakes built on
just one photogenic product
stylish new take on an Italian-American
green white and red favorite the rainbow
cookie traditionally it looks like the
Italian flag right right yes but we
decided to make a pink orange yellow
cookie a green blue and purple cookie
Zola grew up in New York the world
capital of rainbow cookies it's a very
dense cake which makes it seem like a
cookie while rainbow cookies are in
supermarkets and Italian bakeries across
the country she sells hers online I knew
that we had something big and it's just
grown tremendously mainly through social
media just through social media there
was no electricity about a hundred years
ago rainbow cookies were popularized at
bakeries like this one
Ernest lapori's great-grandfather and
great uncle opened Cafe Ferrara in New
York's Little Italy in 1892. there was
really no women allowed until like the
1920s or 30s no women allowed to work
here or to shop in the store not even my
grandmother the daughter
his grandmother may have had the last
laugh today ferrara's traditional
Italian flag rainbow cookie which the
bakery ships Nationwide is based on her
recipe I got to do old school old school
Italian the Cookie's intense almond
flavor actually comes from apricot pits
ground up and cut with a bit of almond
paste we're going to use one of my
grandfather's machines it needs three
the recipe also includes food coloring
this is the cool part
to make three thin cakes which are
compressed overnight get yourself in the
middle add apricot marmalade and some
chocolate and you've got a seven layer
cookie we've got chocolate red apricot
white apricot green chocolate Samantha
Zola's version nearly twice the price of
ferraras has six precise layers I take a
ruler and I make sure every cookie is
exactly the same size
were you like this all your life was
your homework very neat yes each cookie
is 7 8 of an inch wide there it is she
uses pure almond paste food coloring to
create bright colors layers in apricot
or raspberry jams or hazelnut spread and
tops it off with white or dark chocolate
I like to make an S it gives it a good
drip on this side ready
look man down the result and you say two
bites two bites
hmm
two bites
Dana Jacobson found magic right out of
the oven when she visited the kitchen of
legendary Baker and five-time James
Beard award winner Dory Greenspan she
dishes on cookies and a whole lot more
have a good year okay so French cheese
puff normally made with Conte or gruyere
but these have gouda in them and some
cumin also Dory Greenspan welcomed me to
her Connecticut home as she would an old
friend and when you come in you can
smell them baking and so I say hi hand
you one hand you guzier and I said
whatever you need Dory whatever you need
her food just part of the warmth that
envelops you the rest is all Dory I got
married when I was 19. and I taught
myself to cook and bake my mother used
the oven to like hold bread and crackers
and things like that but I found that
baking it was relaxing it was so
satisfying that you would take
ingredients and you can see things
change and you bake to share there are a
million things I love about baking as
evidenced in her cookbook baking with
Dory her 14th in a 30-year span part of
a career that took some warming up to I
was terrible in a professional kitchen
you know I I say baking is easy because
you follow a recipe but I kept changing
the recipe I got fired from my first
baking yeah for Creative insubordination
that same creative insubordination LED
Dory to a writing job at Food and Wine
magazine and eventually cookbook
projects with the likes of Danielle
ballude Julia Child and Pierre ermay
they were all generous they were all
ready to teach me and I learned what was
scary as you were trying to build this
career
I was scared because
I was afraid I didn't know enough I was
afraid I wasn't good enough I wasn't
trained I couldn't say oh look at my
degree from cooking school but I wanted
to so I kept saying yes and being scared
so if you would just
smush it around yep I'm a good assistant
you're a good smoosher she then took
what she learned and passed it on to the
rest of us one cookbook at a time I'd
love to think that the work I do
encourages people to come into the
kitchen and teaches them I Perfection is
overrated I find that
this one's skinny and this one's a
little chubbier they're cute
when something isn't perfect in a way
you're seeing the Maker's fingerprints
on it and what could be better than that
as for leaving her own Mark there's her
New York Times food columns social media
take a spatula and give them a few smart
smacks boom
boom
it's kind of fun
14 cookbooks yeah five James Beard
awards I should be taller I mean like
Siri your list of accolades unbelievable
I think I was so lucky that I found
something that just
filled me Julia Child said famously find
something you're passionate about and
stick to it and there was more she said
we're so lucky
Julia this is pretty as well um she said
we're so lucky because we work in food
and we'll never stop learning she was so
curious so open to new ideas there's
always something new to learn she was
right like when Dory altered her
legendary chocolate cookie recipe at a
friend's urging so this is
a world peace cookie okay 2.0 but it
looks very much like
1.0 except
I added
ingredients that I thought
matched the qualities in women that I
admire Rye flour for groundedness
freeze-dried raspberries for sass even
red chili pepper for unpredictability
when I realized that I could get these
qualities in a cookie that tasted
it's good delicious well you know I just
finished the whole thing so yeah
the cookies just one of the recipes from
baking with Dory I was lucky enough to
devour there was also a spinach
mozzarella parmesan crumble pie ricotta
blueberry coffee cake and the Lisbon
chocolate cake which earned a spot on
the cover we stopped at a cafe that
served only coffee tea in this cake I
loved it but there was no time to find
out how it was made I took a picture of
it and the following day in Paris I
started making this cake just
experimented just to try and get the
flavor that I remembered the look that I
loved dory's travels the inspiration for
many of her cookbooks including her
latest until the coronavirus hit her
inspiration then found at home with her
husband son and Pregnant daughter-in-law
I had people I wanted to feed the food
in the book what I baked is because
I wanted to feed my family which now
includes her granddaughter Gemma born
just a week after the cookbook was
finished and who it's dedicated to
right now are you already thinking about
what's next I'm not always sure what's
next but I'm always thinking of what's
next somebody said to me recently
you should retire and I said
why I love what I do so much that I
can't imagine
not doing it I mean I go into the
kitchen I make something and I think
what if I changed it just a little bit
and it it all starts I can't help myself
and I don't want to and I don't want to
coming up a dash of Technology gets
thrown into the mix making the most
incredible and edible works of art we'll
show you next on the dish
[Music]
brace yourself for the scientific Sugar
Rush ahead A Feast for both the eyes and
the taste buds Jamie wax goes behind the
scenes of a Los Angeles 3D printing lab
whipping up jewel-like Creations you can
pop right into your mouth
in the modern world we hear the term 3D
printing so frequently that it's almost
become meaningless but at a tech slash
culinary startup in downtown Los Angeles
3D printing is creating something very
specific and sweet a lot of these
designs yeah like I we have inspiration
from chefs or just we kind of have some
crazy ideas in the lab and we're just
like okay let's just make this really
fun food product sugar lab creates small
beautiful detailed sculptures every one
of them edible creative director William
who showed us some highlights including
some custom-made designs special for our
visit like these cake toppers tiny bites
of a latte filled with ganache that is a
very complex bite I mean I've got
chocolate I've got peppermint and I've
got coffee flavor in here
but they're all sort of hitting at a
slightly different time and in a
different way yeah we love that kind of
bringing our you know customers through
that experience craft beer bon bons
incorporating various beers into the
filling the visual printing on these is
incredible we kind of took inspiration
from breweries to make really poppy
labels and then yeah with the Shadows we
wanted to really emphasize the that
little pop top on top and they even add
an element of fun and Sparkle to drinks
with these glitter bombs these are lime
flavored printed with edible glitter as
you can see it's melting there with the
glitter I mean that's just fun yeah to
watch much less drink that's just fun
well cheers to your creativity cheers
thank you like many revolutionary ideas
the whole thing started almost by
accident in the college apartment of
founder Kyle Von Hassell who was
studying architecture I basically was
grocery shopping with my wife and we
brought home some cake batter like in a
box and we get into our tiny grad
student apartment and we realized we
didn't have an oven so there was no way
to bake it actually and uh we we thought
what would it be like to actually use
this 3D printer that we've been using
for architectural purposes and pouring
sugar could you 3D print frosting could
it could you make it sculptural could
you add color after some experimenting
his vision eventually grew beyond the
existing capability we realized that the
technology couldn't go much farther
unless we did a lot of research a lot of
homework and developed a 3D printer from
scratch which would require a lot of
innovation a lot of invention that's
when he brought in co-founder and Chief
Operating Officer Megan Bozeman Megan 3D
printing was the focus of your work and
your life at the time when you heard
about this application what did you
first think it's a market that had not
even been tapped into and the technology
is something that could deliver a whole
new product in a whole new way allow
chefs to be creative in a whole new way
to see that firsthand I donned a hair
net required around the equipment and
toured the sugar lab itself so Victoria
this seems like an incredibly fun job in
The Culinary World it absolutely is and
easily the most interesting and
different thing I've ever done in-house
Chef Victoria Johnson walked me through
the process of printing
some of sugar lab's delectable Creations
starting with the computer design I am
re-configuring these strawberries then
to where the magic happens at one of
their 3D printers I'll show you so we
gotta get wow all this powder out of
here now I know where these are right
but I will show you you've done this a
lot so we've got one here
and uh I mean that that's it that's the
whole thing but of course you can see
it's covered in powder so we always give
it a little tap to get all the powder
out of the inside
that is that's really surprising I have
to say it's completely watch the color
the texture and everything just flies up
that's amazing with the right blend of
business creativity and Technology
sugar lab got the attention of The
Culinary Community how important was it
to involve chefs in this process uh it's
been critical the people that we asked
were pastry chefs they were our first
clients nobody would want to buy these
if they were not delicious and so the
chefs really help us bridge that from
beautiful that's what the Architects
really to deliver to beautiful and
delicious and an experience that people
have not had before and collaborations
with chefs have led to Innovative and
even Savory uses of the technology like
Top Chef winner May Lin's 3D printed
quail egg and Las Vegas French chef Yuri
sarcevsky's hyper realistic honeycomb
they see something that they've never
eaten before and then they're surprised
with this the feeling that he's put in
there goat cheese mixed with other
ingredients that he then bakes and
serves and it's an experiential meal for
the customer the instagramable nature of
sugar lab sculptures have led to
collaborations with celebrities like
Kylie Jenner but Kyle Von Hassell still
sees a bigger future for the dream that
started in that college apartment where
do you want this to go I'd love for this
to expand across the country into other
countries in an increasingly urbanized
United States where food scarcity issues
could come up being able to have those
local ingredients and print with local
3D printers I think could make a really
big difference and we want to make sure
the technology is out there and
distributed wildly enough that it can
have that kind of impact
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7. stream
that's right here on CBS News I'm
Michelle Miller we'll see you next time
for another helping of the dish